est-ce que ça peut être intéressant pour
les oiseaux
les mares
pour les curieux de nature
Solène Boivin organise des promenades
intitulées les grands curieux dans la
Haute Vallée de Chevreuse à la rencontre
du patrimoine de la faune et de la flore
les promeneurs avaient rendez-vous pour
suivre la naturaliste venue éveiller
leur curiosité la commune a mis en place
un différents petits jardins pour
protéger la biodiversité donc c'est vrai
que moi je vais parler de toutes ces
actions
qui comme l'arrêt de l'utilisation des
pesticides qui est très importante pour
pour sauvegarder tous ces milieux qui
sont riches et qui accueillent vraiment
beaucoup d'espèces vivantes une balade
entre nature et patrimoine sur les
traces de Robert Doisneau l'artiste
célèbre pour ses photographies
d'après-guerre aymortaliser les instants
de vie à réseux
en c'est le nom du coeur de la ville
l'environnement se fait plus sauvage
l'occasion d'apprendre les secrets d'un
arbuste communément appelé bonnet
d'évêque on a vraiment des fruits qui
vont s'ouvrir qui vont être rose avec du
orange aussi donc des fruits très très
qui vont perdurer l'hiver qui sont pas
comestibles mais par contre c'est un
arbuste avec lequel on peut faire du
fusain d'Europe très facilement des
balades ludiques pour un public avis de
deux Savoie alors moi c'est découvrir le
coin c'est toutes les connaissances
naturalistes et puis comme je veux en
faire mon métier aussi donc je
m'imprègne et en fait de ce que fait
soi-même découverte d'indices de
présence animale sous le soleil automnal
au hasard d'un sentier le public a pu
apercevoir des nids de chenilles
processionnaires pour se protéger ces
insectes peuvent éjecter leur poils
urticants parfois dangereux pour l'homme
un moment se transformer en papillon et
pour ça elles vont faire des chrysalides
mais dans un cocon qu'on voit donc elle
on dit qu'elles vont se nymphoser donc
la processionnaire du personnel elle va
Sony imposer sur le tronc des chaînes
c'est ce qu'on voit sur ce chêne là si
vous êtes un amoureux de la nature et de
l'histoire sachez que ces balades
commentées se déroulent tout au long de
l'année prochain rendez-vous à gambaisoï
le vendredi 4 novembre à la découverte
des plantes sauvages protégées et de
l'arbre girafe